hi I'm Justin McCoy I'm here today to
talk to you about deep learning as a
service and I think I'm gonna talk to
you about and show you how to train a
ninety waste deploy deep learning models
without computers all through API calls
which could make sense to Python
developers so there's only three things
you take away today I want it to be
these three URL ends if nothing you want
to leave and nothing else matters these
are the only three URL URL links that I
want you to walk away with the first one
is a github project that I'm gonna walk
through today using IBM's deep learning
as a service to Train deploy and
evaluate train evaluate and deploy some
machine learning and deep learning model
the next is fiddle github by BM comm f
SDL it is the open source library and
framework that I've seen Watson's deep
learning as a service is built on so
this is the open source code and develop
our IBM comm it's where we're sharing
all of our github projects and all the
are examples of open source projects we
have it IBM ok today we're gonna go
through I want it like level set how
many here how many people here use deep
or have use deep learning you anything
about so this is gonna be you know one
slide quick overview for you I want to
talk about some of the applications of
deep learning let's talk about some deep
learning tasks now what are the tasks
you have to perform in order to train
and evaluate a deep learning model I
want to talk about the tools you use for
training evaluating and deploying deep
learning model I want to talk about deal
as which is our cloud-based deep
learning as a service cloud box one that
we have that a fiddle it's built on
didn't and then we'll walk through codes
to submit and monitor deep learning
tasks use
alright so for those of you that aren't
deep learning I want to catch everybody
up a deep learning is a subset of
machine learning I'm assuming @py data
we are all familiar with machine
learning it is a field of building
models to classify and make predictions
by representation of data and successive
layers with increasingly it is that is a
mouthful we all know that training deep
learning models you're building a neural
net you're building layers of basically
matrices and performing transformations
on those matrices I've just given you an
idea of where deep learning fits in you
have artificial intelligence machine
learning deep learning deep learning is
a very specialized version of machine
learning that is where you're building
these complex layers of may proceed
transformation it's excessively
meaningful layers and representations of
data I know that wasn't you know a a
really technical dive into what deep
learning is but here are some of the
applications of deep learning that you
could use
we have semantic segmentation so that is
I mean we're the internet generation so
everything has to deal with cats I think
using cats is the best way of describing
some of the applications of deep
learning
you have classification and localization
that is can we classify an object and we
can show where an object is in an image
we have object detection again just
showing where an object is in a
detection but in an image that we built
with multiple objects within a single
image the deep learning model for that
is called Yolo has anyone heard of Yolo
she just yellow you only look once you
have image segmentation which again you
can do that for
multiple objects as well in a single
pass and again we're showing dogs and
cats and dogs and cats here other
applications are deep learning more of
the modern stuff I think that top row
there is something we all should be
familiar with object detection object
segmentation the next the next part of
it is generative adversarial networks
has anyone heard of you or used or
created a generative adversarial Network
one person so I'm just showing here an
example of a generative adversarial
Network and that is a network that has
learned to teach itself to create
something new you have a generator and
an evaluator depth to neural networks
and the evaluator is going through and
saying hey is this picture of a bird is
if I'm gonna generate a picture of a
bird is it actually a picture of a bird
if not let's go back through update the
pixels of that generator and then
generate a new image but it fences a
bird and then evaluate it this is a
particularly generative at adversarial
networks is we're using text to produce
images so we've gone through and we've
trained a model to base off the text
produce images that it thinks represent
that text just some kind of high level
overview applications that depend for
deep learning there are for machine
learning deep learning you have a few
different types of use pre trained AI
that is just calling a machine learning
model that's a API endpoint today it's
like your speech-to-text api's or your
image classification api's that
currently exists
you could use transfer learning so you
could take a pre trained model like
imagenet and you could rip off the
bottom layers of that imagenet model
those are those last few layers of the
imagenet model retrain those weights or
whatever your classification pass is in
our case uh in the classification
individual classification paths and then
you could use just that and train that
model on your own domain data that is
transfer learning where you could go the
whole customer route you could design
your entire deep learning neural network
yourself you could create or generate or
find the data you can train that network
from spent building those subsequent
layers of increasing yeah so alright so
these are just some deep learning tasks
that we currently work through you know
you're using pre trained AI you're using
transfer learning or you're building a
new neural network so I really I'm here
to talk to you about some of the tools
that are available today if you are a we
have two different user personas that
I'm showing here we have our traditional
developers and data scientists and
researchers I think a lot of you fit
into that space but you're working in
Python you're working with Jupiter
notebooks you're working with our studio
and your desert developing and designing
your own machine learning algorithms or
you have those non coder clicker data
scientist that is probably your business
analyst that's going through and using a
visual tool in order to create and
evaluate machine manya models without
writing any code and there are a few
tools to do that you have this tool
called spss modeler neural network model
er I know there are others does anyone
use one of these today so they're tools
that you can just pass it data you can
identify the the labels and you could
by the feature it's gonna go through and
it's gonna train a machine learning
model for you you won't have to write
any code it will do the data
transformations for you to get the data
under the right format it's a really
simple if you're going through and you
just want to explore what's available or
what is in that data and then both you
know the traditional non dataset non
code or data scientist and your
developer data scientist once you've had
a model you got to go through and you
have to deploy it in production so I
want to talk I wants to spend a moment
on this slide I've attended a few of the
talks and everyone's going through and
they're using Jupiter Network stupider
notebooks to build and train their
machine learning models but I'm curious
are you running Jupiter notebooks on
your laptops you have a Jupiter notebook
that's deployed in your company that you
connect into remotely that's backed by
some some system you're running locally
anybody else how are you running your
Jupiter notebook to your data science
test today you have a company server and
as that company server just a jupiter
notebook okay you have a you run a
kernel on like a Python three kernels
with all your specialized libraries
deployed here you running it on a
virtual machine I mean that's you know
it's really complicated to go through
and set up the environment to do machine
learning and really I'm talking about
deploying faster today if I wanted to go
and build a system from scratch you know
I probably would need a Linux engineer
at someone that could build a Linux
system for me and then I'm gonna need
someone that can move up the iyer levels
of complexity from that Linux system and
maybe build out some virtual machines so
I'm using VM to abstract out the
hardware
Linux is managing if I'm running virtual
machines I'm either running virtual
machines and kubernetes on top or just
you know Linux with kubernetes are these
terms familiar kubernetes virtual
machines or is anyone going through and
building out there like a deploying on
kubernetes deploying their notebooks on
kubernetes kubernetes is a container
management system so most of our
different notebooks or how i've used it
is deploying a jupiter notebook within a
container the net container has all the
libraries specified from my environment
if I wanted to use SK learn version 1.1
I know it's a much better version than
that but and I want to use my own
company specific libraries I would
create a jus I would create a container
to host all the libraries that I would
all the libraries and then the kernels
for my jupiter notebook and then I could
easily deploy and scale that out as more
and more users in my company want to use
Jupiter notebooks so then it spins up
more containers those containers are
deployed on hardware that hardware you
know it's it's hard to manage all those
containers especially if you're a large
company if you're a one or two person
shop it's I would suggest you use cloud
services but if you're managing this all
for your company you have to manage all
the containers that support all the
libraries across your and your tie or
whatever everyone else
Kerris cafe get the build containers for
specific libraries I think it's really
complicated to do because you need a
wide range a domain expertise to even
get started I just like to throw out
this slide of all the difference
libraries and frameworks to kind of
showcase the complexity
yes we all depend on so to abstract out
from some of that complexity there is a
open source framework built by IBM that
we actually base our deep learning
framework upon and that is fiddle its
fabric for deep learning and if you have
one of the three links I wanted to share
that we're most important right our one
of them was fiddle github that ibm.com
/ft
you should go out there and take a look
at that library if you are building your
own deep learning framework today as it
solves a lot of these complexities of
managing that kubernetes cluster
managing what containers have assigned
GPUs managing other libraries have
containers of the different libraries
and then it adds it adds some special
sauce managing of the training models
training different experiments and I'm
going to talk about the different why
you need experiments and then monitoring
how do I know when my deep learning job
is completed there's a research paper
here I linked to and then I also have a
IBM viz deploy fiddle so I want I want
to make it easy we want to make it easy
for people that get started with a point
so there is a another github project
that goes through and describes in great
detail how to deploy fabric for deep
learning on your own kubernetes cluster
we run an Amazon kubernetes cluster or
an IBM kubernetes cluster or Google
kubernetes cluster
I have here it includes tools for again
monitoring your jobs but it also allows
you to visualize your jobs and know how
do I visualize it's my the models I've
trained are getting more accurate you
know there's the validation accuracy
going up or is it is it getting more
accurate as a validation accuracy going
down I said only three links but this is
a fourth link
I know ever you know several of you said
that you use Cooper installed locally or
Jupiter installed on your company's
server we have a school that IBM called
Watson studio actually think of it as
our IDE for artificial intelligence it's
a fourth link ibm.com
or slash cloud force class Oh Watson
studio I'm actually we're going to be
using this today in my demonstration in
my nd exam we're only gonna really be
using the deep learning service again
the deep learning service is built on
top of fiddle it has some additional
functionality and is available to you as
a cloud-based service where you can just
make API calls in order to use it
watson studio is a GUI built on top and
brings together a lot of these that
tooling that I showed in the tools of
the trade
in Watsons to vo there's actually a
service that I'm gonna use in my demo
and it's called the actually don't like
the term Watson but it's a machine
learning service and what this machine
learning service does is it provides you
GPU compute scalable GPU compute it
gives you distributed deep learning so
if I wanted to spread my deep learning
job across multiple GPUs rights across
multiple containers it gives you
distributed deep learning you have a
neural network model er I'm not gonna
show that today because that's one of
those visual clicker tools maybe I'll
show you what it what it looks like but
it's not a it's more of a
point-and-click a GUI tool in the web
you have model hosting so what do I do
when I train my deep neural network my
machine learning model how do I put that
model into production and consume it
through an API in point you could do
that really simply with just a few
clicks of the mouse here in Watson
studio we could monitor the lineage so
if I trained a machine learning model
how do I know it's the most up-to-date
model how do I know one of those last
time it was trained what data was linked
to so there is a tool to monitor the
lineage of that model that I've trained
and built in Watson studio there is this
concept of continuous and learning it's
just a simple way of getting new data
training the model reevaluating is it
more is it more accurate or less
accurate if it's more accurate just
redeploy that model we can automate that
stuff and that process using continuous
learning and Watson machine Emma Watson
machine learning service you have a
visual model builder so in addition to
that neural network model err where
you're building those neural network
layers with a point-and-click GUI
interface you could do the same thing
with machine learning
so you can build your transformation
pipeline using a point-and-click
interface versus a writing toad you
could easily download the coronel models
it supports the jupiter notebooks and
what I'm most interested in is deep
learning as a service so what is deep
learning as a service right again this
is built on top of fiddle it is IBM's an
IBM product on top it'll part of
Watson's studio or IDE for artificial
intelligence so as a user I've gone
through and I've trained her I've gone
through and I've designed a neural
network and I'm using you know let's say
Karras in my I would have to go through
and find a container that supports Karis
it's connected to a GPU in order to
perform my training well what if I
wanted to train multiple versions of
this neural network I want to do hyper
parameter optimization now change the
number of chins to batch size that I'm
training my network with train the size
of the convolutional layer changed the
dropout rate so you know deep learning
is still this kind of it's more of a
part than a science and I mean it's it's
silly to say it's art to the size but
there is no best practice for designing
your network if there is a best network
design and you you know of it I'm very
interested or whatever domain space that
you'd know the best network design in so
how do you go through and you find and
train a model that's is as is the most
accurate you go through and you submit
multiple experiments you Trent you build
a neural network you change these
parameters again the dropout rate that
attach size the
any you know like any of your optimizers
you can spot those out and then you
submit a job to retrain to this cluster
of compute this is that distributed deep
learning built on top of kubernetes and
what I'm showing here in the photo is a
image of a person me submitting Mike
Harris training job and in my case
training job I've specified a variety as
different hyper parameters I'm changing
the dropout rate simplest one here all
right maybe changing back side and
submitting that job to my cluster and
having it processed all those jobs in
parallel so this allows me to train and
do those experiments in parallel and see
the results back up
you know after one day versus seven days
you know if I have a deep learning job
that takes one full day to train I don't
want to wait one day to look at the
results and then submit another job
waited a get the results I want to do
this in parallel on a cluster every time
the scenes this is all a again which is
kubernetes containers and sitting in
each of these containers are connected
to GPUs yes and the first link what I
presented P white data underscore deep
learning IBM that biz for /py data on
the score deep learning
there is a example of performing grid
search on a a really simple deep
learning model it's just doing fashion
it's doing clothing identification and I
actually think random is better than
grid because grid you have to do all the
difference potential
and they say that random might get 95%
of the way there without having to go
through the entire you know space of
option talk here at the conference do so
some of the interfaces we have to this
deep learning framework the same
interfaces we have to fiddle right so
you have a API I can go through and I
can make API calls to submit my training
jobs to monitor my training jobs to
deploy my models I can use a
command-line interface to do the same
thing and this is really all just an
abstraction of that base API now I'm
gonna walk through an example using the
Python SDK in order to submit your model
tune your hyper parameters evaluate your
model and then you have a GUI I'm
actually showing here the GUI from
Watson studio and here is the neural
network model err so if I wanted to just
go through and click and design my
neural network with all the
convolutional layers and design the
hyper parameters without writing any
code I can do that here in this visual
monitor modeler and then if I wanted to
see just again through the GUI what it
looks like for you know to compare all
my training runs compare all of my
experiments across all the hyper
parameters I could use this the visual
tool here to show a you know the graph
of the loss and graph of the validation
accuracy it's being hinged on the other
image and then show all the different
training runs in my experiment
so I better get going on the actual
coding part of this right
so really it's good timing so how do you
submit an experiment to a cluster of GPU
enabled nodes monitor progress of beli
where results download training models
and deploy the model and reproduction
all in Python let's go I'm doing it in
Python because py data right like we
gotta use Python I could easily have
come up here and just showing you the
GUI interfaces but Python is more
interesting so if I'm training a deep
learning model or several tasks that I
go through you know I design my neural
network I vary the options my hacker
parameters I submit training jobs and
then I evaluate those training jobs and
this is all kind of encapsulated in
fiddle and deep learning as a service as
an experiment and we're gonna go through
and we're gonna perform tens or hundreds
or thousands of experiments depending on
my parameter space in order to do that I
break it down even further here
submitting and monitoring deep learning
tasks in pipe Python first we're gonna
have to configure our setup then we're
gonna go through the design very trained
evaluate and then we're gonna go through
and publish so look at some code I'm
just showing here I'll post a
presentation online if you want to
follow through you can also follow on
the links that I shared at the beginning
I have to go and create two services I
can easily do this for an API call as
well but here are just quick ways of
creating the machine learning service
and all my training data and my results
data and the cloud for all the
experiments and training runs I run are
stored in cloud object storage now I'm
using our ibm's cloud object storage but
could just as easily use s3
all right these are the libraries
there's a Python library
Watson machine learning client it's an
SDK for the machine learning service and
then here's a another github repository
that is it's unofficial but it's
abstracting out even that Python SDK so
it makes it easier to submit monitor and
train their jobs so it's actually look
this shouldn't this should it be strange
to anybody that's familiar with deep
learning I'm going through here and I'm
building a sequential neural network
I've got 13 different layers resulting
in a categorization of 10 classes right
cuz everyone's seen or built this
control has anyone built a sequential
neural network before okay so this
should look very familiar right this is
like your hello world of deep learning
well in order to change this hello world
of deep learning on to to work in the
deep learning as a service environment
to work in the fiddle environment we
have to change just a few things all
right since we're storing our data and
cloud object storage we have to set the
data directory where we're gonna get our
data from and that's gonna be an
environmental variable and then we have
to set our log directory where we want
our logs to go and we have to set a
results directory but we want a results
to go using cloud objects storage this
is all just gonna be thrown into buckets
right so you're gonna have a bucket with
all my training data bucket with my log
data in a bucket with my results data
which includes my trained model
so next here is that same hello world of
machine learning that same hello world
neural network but I'm going to do some
hyper parameter to knee so I have a
helper function hyper parameters that is
loading a dictionary of parameters from
a configuration file and these pepper
parameters you can see here I'm
specifying number of filters filter size
different filter sizes pool sizes drop
out you know drop out values so there's
a huge you know like a huge space a huge
matrices of different combinations that
we could build and we could run a grid
search or we could run a random search
to find out what combinations of these
hyper parameters trains the best model
but that's going to take tens or
hundreds of different training jobs in
order to find and train the most
accurate model you could also use these
hyper parameters like size and number of
epochs wherever you want so I've gone
through and I've rewritten my hello
world of neural networks and I've added
my hyper parameter tuning feature set to
it I just want to go through and package
up that experiment and my hyper
parameters helper function into a zip
file so once I have a zip file I want to
use this of I've got my design my neural
network I now want to go through and
begin the process of submitting that
neural network it's a minute it will
cross all the different hyper parameter
spaces that are that are available just
showing here some of the helper
utilities that are in the example
project I shared right I'm using
Watson's studio utilities to configure
access with Python to my cloud object
storage and to the Watson machine
learning
and I'm using this project utilities to
create a new closet where I'm gonna keep
my experiments and training runs and
monitor and manage those I've got 10
more minutes
I'll save 5 minutes for questions so
I'll go really fast for this piece here
is a in my project utilities method here
I have class I have a method to simplify
uploading training data about object
storage all right so I pass in my cloud
object storage credentials JSON string
and then I can easily upload all my
training data to cloud object storage
the next is I want to design my
experiment the experiment includes all
the different training runs that are
available for to do the comparison of my
model I'm gonna use a v1 hundreds GPU I
want to use it distributed deep learning
so I'm gonna use to be 100 GPUs I give
it a custom name I tell it the framework
that I'm using we're gonna use grid
search and I'm passing in the studio to
utilities and project utilities that
helps my experiment know where my data
is I have another helper function again
in the sample project I've shared or
it's creating a random search yes I
wasn't using grid search I'm using
random search so that's going through
and building random parameter spaces all
right and it's saving that random
parameter space to a config dot JSON
file and then it's and altering that zip
file I have for my project would that
specialized config dot JSON file now I
have a new truck or a new experiment so
a new training run with a config die
JSON file with a
one set of Pi programmers and I submit
and execute that experiment and then I
loop through again and I generate
another random config dot JSON file and
I update the config die JSON file in my
zip file and my zip file I package that
up and I submit it as another experiment
to my D last my compute cluster so it's
going through and submitting multiple
experiments using a random you know a
random assortment of hyper parameters
hyper parameter optimization running in
parallel on this distributed deep
learning framework I have another helper
function here it's called experiment or
it's a print experiment summary so it's
gonna through it's gonna go through and
and just monitor those experiments that
have been submitted and then a prudence
summary of of how they're doing is are
they completed running yet so some of
these experience experiments in the
example I think they take 20 minutes per
experiment and you run them in parallel
you could do 30 experiments in 20
minutes
you want to print a summary of all those
I use tensor board when I want to
evaluate so I here's just the code I use
in order to have tensor board point at
my s3 bucket or my result is Tory
here's what it would look like if I was
using Watson studio and not using code
again I quick-quick II click-through
interface and I've also kind of
simplified that deployment saving into
point of the model by abstracting out
the the many API calls that are needed
in order to do that as these save and
deploy model functions okay I went
through that kind of quickly but all the
source code that you saw here isn't a
github project its py data underscore
deep learning and that's it I'm Justin
McCoy I've got probably four minutes
left does anyone have any questions then
parameter search how do I use my
multiple GPUs well if I was running a
large data science team how would each
person that's submitting jobs who had
you know that that GPU farm would be
utilized by all the different members of
my team performing experiments
distributed learning does that right
it's built into fiddle I don't know how
they do it but it is open source so you
could go check it out
that makes it so you're asking
documentation with benchmarks so the
question is how much does running across
multiple GPUs increase performance so if
I continually add GPUs to my to my
configuration will that linearly scale
performance there is a research paper
from IBM that they've been able to
achieve 95% linear scale
when it's taxing GPUs in a network
cluster so they added 256 GPUs and they
received they were able to scale with a
95% linear performance and I could give
you information about that any other
questions
if you download the code and you run
into any question if you have any
problems you could reach out to me on
via email or Twitter interested to hear
what you're building
[Applause]